today we are flipping the script and
having you ask us any questions that you
want so who's ready for some q a or we
like to call it
true
all right let's get started first up is
vicky
where's vicki hi vicky hi drew hi hi
vicky i love that you stand up it's so
like
like scholastic it's like show-and-tell
right yeah totally yeah vicki what is
your question so i have a four-year-old
uh he loves to draw markers crayons
paint anytime he sees something that he
can draw with he starts drawing so got a
couple of his drawings here
um he's so proud when he draws them
he gives them to me and he says mom look
isn't it is it don't you love it
i have no idea what these are
i i don't even know what to say
because
i couldn't even tell you what he was
thinking
can you help me figure this out
yeah um
[Applause]
i'm getting potato people
that are actually like walking in the
snow or some type of trail and like
those two are hanging back and the other
two have made it forward or oh yeah um i
was getting uh like a solar system at
first you know what i mean look at the
celestial yes like the yeah go to the
next one the next one all right
i mean i see an airplane
okay i see the inside of a refrigerator
like
the ingredients you know what i mean
like that's what this is like a weird
warshack test isn't it yeah
also you're an attorney i am well you
know you just need to negotiate
uh here in this situation
um
maybe
ask him some questions about what's in
his mind when he's drawing them okay
yeah or buy him a book about jackson
pollock right it's a great idea okay
thank you
great and you may have the next big
artist you might have van gogh in your
family
thanks vicky
[Music]
you